did you have like when you when we were
when we were first getting ready to
launch the first couple of episodes did
you think like oh i want the show to be
like this yeah i really thought when we
first started i was like
because when we started
it was in the middle of the bad times
and you know on tv
this man was saying all kinds of racist
[ __ ]
and then like we got into that gray area
remember when we were like no one on the
news will say the word racist and
everybody was mad
but like i was madder than everyone
combined yeah and i was like we are
we're just parroting these things crazy
man said
but
we aren't calling the crazy things crazy
and that is hurting all of us
so that was my main goal was to be like
you gotta call a [ __ ] a [ __ ] so that
was
that was basically where i was coming
from
and when you say the crazy racist man
you're referring to prince charles
that's right prince charles right
remember how black will the baby be oh
my god i shouted it i shouted it for a
good month after that article came out
never has a tv special delivered to such
an extreme degree
i know that's right every inch of that
interview was like you gotta be kidding
all of america simultaneously when that
fact came out went from oh no should i
go to bed too yeah
[Laughter]
so there are a million sketch and
variety shows on tv right what makes a
sketch an amber ruffin show sketch
um
well
you're a little buzzed when you do it
yes
um no i don't know what makes it a
amber ruffin sketch is
okay this is my secret feeling these are
my secret feelings
when i do when i am performing
to get laughs
what i think is the right thing to do
where i want to be is
i want to be feeling a little
embarrassed it's great and that's what i
think is the key like that's why i like
singing and dancing because i'm not a
good singer dancer right at me so and
then because of that it feels like
a little embarrassing so i love that and
then also like
you know if you tell a joke you know the
joke is crisp and an a plus joke that's
great and sometimes you tell a c plus
joke and you're like
i love that feeling yeah um
i i love it i love living on the edge i
think that's something i really admire
about you knowing you both
professionally and personally is i think
so many people go through life and
through comedy thinking like i want to
do the thing i know will be safe
and i feel like you are the one person
who i know who's not like okay it's a
little dangerous but i'll do it you
court that feeling i want to constantly
be in danger yeah not restless not
recognized i don't i don't think of you
as someone who's reckless who's like
let's just do this and who cares how it
goes but you are always kind of
searching for like what's the edge of
what could be interesting what could be
possible what could be a little too
crazy or a little too serious like i
think that's such an interesting place
to explore because i think that's where
we get some of the biggest surprises on
the show
we've had a couple sketches where we're
like oh no man
this is either great or terrible yes and
i feel like most people would be like
well if we don't know we should cut it
and you're like if we don't know we got
to find out
we need to find out all we need our goal
is to become experts by the end of this
yeah and you can't become an expert by
being safe that's right you can only
become an expert by being in
horrible danger
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you